jérôme pineau ancien coursier à vélo
chez des libéraux et cofondateur du club
le collectif des livres autonome de
paris bonjour merci d'être avec nous
comment est-ce que vous accueillez cette
condamnation de des livres ou le voile
est levé en fait la justice a fini par
lever le voile sur les sur les pratiques
de des livres ou notamment c'est
important parce que jusqu'à présent tout
les toutes les actions qui avaient été
menées à terme concerner des plateformes
qui avaient ou fait faillite ou disparus
là on est sur une plate forme qui encore
en activité et est plus qu'une activité
parce que c'est un des leaders du marché
et donc ça montre bien qu'en fin de
compte il s'agit pas il s'agit pas de
condamner de faire des proces sur ds sur
des morts mais que les plates formes qui
sont encore en activité sont
condamnables au niveau de leurs
pratiques et donc ça permet de lever le
voile je me disais sur l'escroquerie
l'escroquerie de départ qui est de faire
passer des gens des gens pour des
indépendants alors qu'ils ne le sont pas
pourtant l'entreprise sur son modèle
correspond aux nombreux livres justement
qu'ils sont libres de travailler comme
ils l'entendent comment est ce que vous
prenez 7
cette défense de des libéraux c'est pas
comme ça que fonctionne la loi c'est pas
parce qu'une entreprise ou même parce
qu'une quantité de travailleurs décident
d'être indépendant en plus ils n'ont pas
décidé ont ils n'ont pas le choix d'être
indépendante pour travailler sur cette
plateforme la la loi fonctionne pas
comme ça c'est pas assez pas le choix de
l'un ou de l'autre
c'est la façon dont ils travaillent qui
détermine si ils sont indépendants ou
pas ils ont beau vouloir rester comme ça
rester travailler comme ça le fait est
qu'il ya un moment c'est considéré par
la loi comme des méthodes de salariat
des livres ou dit qu'ils sont
indépendants pour pas payer les
cotisations sociales du fait qu'il soit
salarié il pourrait être salarié un
responsable de délai vous avait dit il
ya quelques années que cela leur
coûterait pas plus cher mais c'est parce
que les gens voulaient être indépendant
non c'est des livres ou et hybrides qui
ont intérêt à mettre ça dans la tête des
gens pour les faire bosser soi-disant
comme quand ils veulent sauf qu'en fait
quand les travailleurs bosse quand ils
veulent avec tout un tas de contraintes
pour accéder à cette liberté de
travailler quand on veut donc c'est de
la subordination
ailleurs en europe des libéraux a déjà
été condamné c'est le cas notamment aux
pays bas et en espagne quel est le fond
du problème finalement le fond du
problème c'est encore une fois qu'ils
font passer des travailleurs qui devrait
être salarié pour des travailleurs
indépendants c'est le noeud du problème
tout ça pour s'exonérer des cotisations
sociales
alors ça évidemment dans une dans un
marché comme la france sur un secteur
comme la france où on est dans une
atmosphère de start up politique on voit
que c'est cette mouvance libérale
ultralibéral plaît aux politiques mais
il n'empêche que sur le terrain on voit
des gens qui sont payés de moins en
moins chers qui sont obligés de rouler
de plus en plus loin de plus en plus
vite avec tous les drames que ça que ça
même est-ce que du coup il va y avoir un
effet domino suite à cette première on
parle d'une cinquantaine de procédures
selon donc le plaignant dans quel état
d'esprit sont vos ex collègues sachant
que c'est de plus en plus difficile de
gagner sa vie quand on roule pour des
livres où tout un tas de livreurs qui
roule des fois depuis depuis un an deux
ans trois ans s'aperçoivent que en fin
de compte le meilleur moyen de gagner sa
vie avec des lions c'est peut-être en
effet d attaquer en justice parce que
quand on voit que ce jeune a travaillé
six mois il a gagné trente mille 30
mille euros sur la base sur la base d'un
salaire net de 2500 euros
2500 euros calculé sur son chiffre
d'affaires ils ont pas été chercher très
loin
donc voilà de certaines personnes qui
bossent depuis un an deux ans trois ans
se disent ah bah oui en fin de compte
j'ai travaillé dur pour juste avoir du
pouvoir d'achat bas pour me permettre de
consommer mois par mois ma vie là je
vais pouvoir attaquer et peut-être dans
deux trois ans parce que les choses vont
s'accélérer maintenant qu'on a des
décisions
je pourrais je pourrai récupérer 60 70
mille cent mille euros 6 gb/s si j'ai
gagné trois ans sur la basse est calculé
sur la base du chiffre d'affaires et pas
sur la base d'un smic comme beaucoup de
gens aimeraient le faire penser qu est
ce qui va se passer ces prochaines
semaines selon vous les prochaines
semaines des actions vont être mis en
place parce que des livres où le hasard
du calendrier
on a fait qu hier on avait une réunion
avec des livreurs parisiens et des
cadres de des livres ou pour répondre à
des questions à des problématiques qui
sont pas répondu
donc des actions vont être menées dans
quelques jours dans quelques jours
j'invite aussi à une conférence de
presse qu on donnera
le 12 février au 15 rue de la fontaine
au roi avec notamment kevin mention
l'avocat qui s'est occupé de cette
affaire pour rentrer peut-être un petit
peu plus dans les détails et pour
expliquer à tout un tas de gens comment
ça se passe et comment ça va se passer
merci beaucoup d'avoir répondu à nos
questions et gentils mots je rappelle
josé texte ex livreur à des livres ou et
cofondateur du club le collectif des
livreurs autonome de paris